ll reste dans cette maison de 1789
la france connaît sa révolution le
couvent des carmélites est dévastée ces
religieuses sont poursuivis le dialogue
des carmélites et mis en scène au
théâtre montansier il volonté commune du
metteur en scène et directeur du théâtre
c'est une pièce que j'ai vu aussi
beaucoup d'années période importante de
ma vie et c'était une façon de rendre
hommage à tout ça et de rendre hommage
aussi à 4 montant cible favorite est la
pièce pose des grandes questions sur la
fois sur le rapport à la mort sur la
spiritualité de chacun d'entre nous sur
le son exigence aussi sur la politique
puisque malheureusement les révolutions
qui sont nécessaires taux souvent mal
l'oeuvre fleuve de georges bernanos
ramener ici à 3h regroupe 19 comédiens
sur scène
une plongée dans la france du xviiie
siècle avec un lien fort avec
l'actualité
évidemment là on a situé la majeure
partie de l'action xviiie siècle monde
la révolution mais par quelques petits
clins d'oeil à la fin on a transporté
l'époque d'une part au moment où
l'auteur allemand qui est une femme qui
retrouve von le fort écrit la nouvelle
dont s'est inspiré bernanos au moment de
la montée du fascisme en allemagne et
puis de nos jouets c'est effectivement
c'est tout le moment où une religion
peut être remise en cause quelle que
soit d'ailleurs en 1794 les seize
carmélites seront guillotinés
leur destin est à découvrir jusqu'au 10
novembre
montant 17 mai sur les places
fort d'une fois tous les carrefours